Cushing Oklahoma is a small town with a
big job in the oil industry it is the
oil pipeline crossroads of America and
that made it the logical place to become
the nation's oil storage hub right now
we're just shutting in wells I mean
doing whatever we can to just reduce
production to the minimum agree we can
now one tank after another stands on a
landscape lined with storage farms
brimming with crude waiting for delivery
but with oil at historically low prices
the crude keeps flowing in as sellers
wait for higher prices and Cushing is
filling up fast it's the world's largest
storage home and about 76 million
barrels storage everybody scrambled to
find space that's why we're saying use
of ocean-going tankers just tankers with
no destination full of oil waiting for
better days and bigger prices nearby gas
sells for under $1 a gallon it's hard to
believe that the oil industry could face
worse than when sellers had to pay
buyers to take this stuff off their
hands but that's what happened on April
20th when prices went below zero but
with prices going nowhere and storage
filling up fast the worst could be yet
to come with the benchmark West Texas
Intermediate Oil below $20 a barrel now
and with oil futures not selling for
more than $40 until 2022 bankruptcies
and shutdowns have already begun
oil storage Rises production is shutting
down refineries on average are operating
in the u.s. below 70% some could soon
refuse to fulfill their contracts to buy
oil invoking a clause that makes it null
and void in case of an act of god virus
or situation supply balloons period it's
it's a major imbalance between supplying
a dramatic imbalance with no sign of
ending anytime soon john Hendren
al-jazeera
Chicago